aujourd'hui on fait les deux ans de la
chaîne et pour ça je vous ai demandé me
poser quelques questions sur facebook et
twitter
c'est l'heure d'y répondre
donc est revenu le plus souvent c'est
mon parcours scolaire
donc j'ai fait première terminale s j'ai
décroché un bac avec mention bien
j'étais le type d'élèves si tu veux
qu'ils travaillaient pas trop mais qui
était très curieux donc je serai pas mal
à la fin du cours pour poser des
questions et toulouse et des gens qui
disent que c'est un petit peu un panneau
moi j'avais passé comme ça je vous sers
comme un curieux
l'éveil derrière moi ils sont en train
de fumer un petit pétard tranquille le
matin sur le quai du rer ou au calme ça
c'était premier à la terminale s donc le
bac
ensuite j'avais j'ai été grave entre
médecine et prépa hec puis ce qui n'a
rien à voir mais j'ai pas mangé une
hésitation entre les deux les deux plus
c'est vachement je suis allé en prépa
hec parce que c'était un truc où je
trouvais que les qualités pour faire un
bon préparationnaires hec choqué à puce
les qualités pour ça que pour être un
bon médecin donc je suis parti là dedans
et c'était les deux meilleures années de
ma vie niveau enfin intellectuellement
c'était incroyable beaucoup il fait très
chaud ici beaucoup beaucoup de maths 9
heures de maths par semaine et c'était
ma matière forte mais même à rêver de
majorer et tout donc c'était vraiment je
kiffais les maths
ensuite le deuxième bloc c'était
géopolitique beaucoup beaucoup de
géopolitique donc pareil j'adorais ça
j'aurais presque pu faire des hauts
lieux des coups de fil faire des coups
des coups d'état par exemple est le
troisième bloc c'était culture g avec
littérature et philosophie c'était genre
vraiment le kiff jetant dans vlog là
je regardais plainte et vidéos c'est sa
plus sévère
donc ça c'était quand j'étais en prépa
après je partis en école de commerce
bonjour je fais un bastian asie
continuent donc ouais je leur école de
commerce
et là j'ai apprise en hd sur le tout ce
qui est what the market
donc c'est ce qui m'a pas mal aidé pour
youtube j'étais un des changes et
matières aussi au canada et là où j'ai
vu jamais un mano à mano final de klaus
mann et c'était vachement cool mais bon
ça de mon petit tu as la philo bien sûr
les lunettes pour tous à la limite avec
le site il ya un gars qui pense qu'ici
de pouce mais elle tue c'est que en fait
avec des lunettes de vue je te promets
je te jure que quand je joue je vois de
l'essec
on en est là donc voilà pour terminer
sur mon parcours scolaire l'école de
commerce va aussi apporter la vie
associative
j'ai eu la chance d'être président du b2
et donc on avait un budget de 200 mille
euros à gérer enfin c'était un gros truc
et j'aimerais juste un mémoire à finir
et j'aurai terminé avec l'école de
commerce et sa mémoire qui est sur le
placement produit sur youtube donc voilà
il faut que faut que je leur ai dit j'ai
tout et je peut être avoir besoin de
vous ça sera sur la page facebook je
pense que je peux te faire une
expérience où le faire deux vidéos avec
un faux placements de produits un peu
différent sur les deux et on va voir
genre lequel il le mieux dans l'intérêt
de tout le monde des gens qui regardent
la vidéo de youtube heures et de la
marque faire le placement produit le
plus optimale possible si je devais
partir avec un philosophe en vacances je
pense que je partirai avec soi
marcorelle soit sénèque parce que c'est
non seulement des philosophes
en plus ils sont stoïciens donc pas trop
stylé je suis moche comme je vous
l'avais dit dans ma première faq
d'ailleurs c'est votre question mais pas
dans cette faq elle est possiblement
dans la première effectuée
sachez le donc comme je le dis dans la
première fois que j'aime beaucoup le
stoïcisme et donc à échanger avec eux
sur ces idées là c'est cool et c'est le
moderniser le stoïcisme par rapport à la
société actuelle
c'est encore mieux et en plus c'est des
hommes politiques marcorelle notamment
empereurs romains qui a mené plein de
guerre donc on va forcément ils ont
plein de truc intéressant de raconter je
pense est une question qui vu le nombre
de likes vous intéresse beaucoup c'est
peut-on vivre de philo sans être prof de
philo je pense que la question que tous
vous les posez c'est est peut-on gagner
sa vie en fait avec la philo sans être
prof de philo et je pense que c'est très
compliqué pour être honnête parce que
même ceux qui font ce qu'ils sont
conférencier même ceux qui écrivent des
bouquins et c'est à un moment ou un
autre
souvent très souvent ils ont été prof de
philo je devais prendre mon cas moi
aujourd'hui je ne vis pas de philo ce
qui me permet de me nourrir c'est le
rewind donc l'émission que je fais avec
20 minutes et dailymotion espion mais ce
que je fais sur youtube avec la philo
masse est quasiment rien on est très
très loin de même ne serait-ce que sur
vivre en banlieue parisienne quoi c'est
l'argent poche au global je parle
évidemment il ya des mois où tu as plus
par exemple le mois du bac il ya plus de
trafic il ya plus de vue et donc voila
tu as plus tu as plus de rémunération
mais ça reste très faible quoi donc
vivre de la philo sans cette prof de
philo
ou sans avoir été prof de philo c'est
berchot on sait jamais peut-être que
grâce à vous je vais y arriver je touche
du bois qu'elles déréférencent en humour
c'est que l'art en jim carrey raid sécu
n'a pas brisé la tat lui the eu quelque
chose sur la région où les inconnus
aussi raymond devos proust et guillon
les lignes elles seules les monty python
et la question avant que je reparte mais
cette vidéo n'est pas fini la faq
continue c'est juste la session tout de
suite
l'intégration des moules frites ça c'est
un problème ça est clairement un
problème aujourd'hui le programme avec
les moules frites en france c'est un
problème clairement qui est français 1
parce que la société belge a clairement
résolus la situation nous notre problème
c'est que il ya beaucoup de progrès à
faire en terme d'audience aux moules
frites puisqu'aujourd'hui il n'ya que
léon qui permettent cette intégration
l'a donc si on le porte étendard de
l'intégration moules frites et ça je
l'en remercie
mais clairement on voit que la société
est en train de mettre des bâtons dans
les roues à cette intégration là en
utilisant le moule par exemple pour
différentes choses par exemple une moule
c'est ça peut être le sexe féminin d'une
femme ça peut être la chance d'y avoir
de la moule donc voilà on essaie de
dénaturer le mot moule et ça c'est pas
fait gratuitement
ça s'est fait avec une volonté derrière
de nuire à la moule frites et j'aimerais
juste que tout le monde en prenne
conscience et je te remercie pour ta
question je te remercie pour ta question
parce qu'on en parle pas assez notamment
sur youtube français je suis mort frites
je voulais te permet à clé bon il ya une
question qui a beaucoup de gens qui me
posent sur internet c'est une demande
quand est ce qui m est venu le goût pour
la philo
est ce que tu sais ou pas non non tu
sais pas ce qu'ils appellent des qui dit
non
qu'est-ce que vous
je sais pas
juste pas
c'est comme ça tu
tu t'es réveillé j'étais touché par la
pêche de du bide aux eaux
hop
thor
je passe ma vie dans le rer ou pas qu'on
verrait les mines de la moria
hier tu es plutôt sauce blanche ou
harris à whitehorse date soit je sais ce
que tu as super pouvoirs year to make
your interest in what should à coup
c'est russe hier les nouvelles marques
comme quoi les rnr son volume
tu confirmes non c'est le tiers
ça représente quoi quelqu'un pour toi le
soulagement est sérieuse il ya ça vient
d'où ce don pour les mâles de mer allant
de chez beenox whitelock sur google si
c'est maïté blague genre tu vois on en
doute et genre ton caca des trucs un peu
amc hualien drogue et un bar n'ont pas
apparemment pas mal de mer les blagues
pourries les blagues pourries ça t'en
fais pas pourri pourri ça vient d'où
second en fait c'est simple c'est une
vraie question
ouais c'est ma maison il ya un mec qui a
posé sa souris n'a besoin de ces russes
et c'est quoi ces vannes pourries
pluriel d'ailleurs van plusieurs vins de
pourriture et les femmes avant de nous
quitter il ya trois questions que vous
m'avez posé au qu'elle voudrait vous
répondre
la première c'est la philo au lycée un
rom demandiez si je pensais que c'était
bien enseigner et tout pour être honnête
franchement oui ça va combien y at il
encore de pays dans le monde où la philo
est obligatoire au lycée le fait que
déjà en france seul soit ça c'est génial
ça c'est génial parce qu'il ya plein de
pays où ça départ on part de loin les
gars on parle de très très loin après si
ça ne tenait qu'à moi on les tue dir est
peut-être un petit peu plus tôt genre
par exemple même beaucoup plus tôt pour
être honnête je la verrais bien en
primaire quoi par exemple trance pen
light
l'après coup de fil voilà comment je
vois les choses d'avoir aidé le coup de
fil je vais apporter des outils de
réflexion genre un tournevis une pince à
un marteau accèdent ensuite ce que je
veux faire c'est montrer qu autour de
nous il ya plein de choses qui à priori
ne sont pas sujet à réflexion
mais qui en fait le son ça c'est ce qui
va arriver en septembre sur la chaîne
ensuite l'étape qui va encore plus loin
c'est de réfléchir sur l'actualité mais
ça viendra encore plus tard traité de
l'actus un truc qui me tient vraiment à
coeur et poissons avant même de faire
via les vidéos je le ferai part par
d'autres trucs par d'autres biais
et vous serez bientôt à former de ça
normalement ce sera pour les cent mille
abonnés
j'espère et d'ailleurs j'en profite pour
rappeler que voilà le coup de fil c'est
finalement le starter de quelque chose
il faut pas penser que cette chaîne sera
cantonné à de la vulgarisation de
philosophie par des auteurs c'est tout
et c'est une bonne nouvelle
sinon ce sera un petit peu chiant
rencontre est quelqu'un qui m'a demandé
quand est ce que j'allais rencontrer mes
fans
la fan c'est assez particulier
d'utiliser ce terme via l'un d'entre
vous d'ailleurs qui m'a demandé comment
j'allais appeler cette communauté j'aime
qu'il ya plein de youtube heures qui
donne est différente non à leur
communauté
vous savez j'en ai aucune idée ce que je
déteste c'est vraiment étiqueter les
choses parce que j'ai peur ensuite ne
pas pouvoir en sortir
donc j'ai pas envie que vous appelez les
philosophes par exemple j'ai pas envie
de ça j'ai pas envie de vous donner de
noms
pour moi vous êtes juste genre des potes
quoi est d'ailleurs bas on peut avoir en
contre donc là j'ai rencontré certains
d'entre vous à l'année aux castes et
c'était vraiment cette ambiance là ce
que je faisais ce qui en fait je faisais
une sorte de cercle et on discutait tous
chacun prenait la parole sur un sujet et
tous ses disques et enfin c'était trop
bien donc voilà ça fait deux ans que
cette chaîne existe je voulais vous dire
merci parce qu'il ya deux ans je
n'aurais pas pensé que ça puisse prendre
un tel impact notamment au niveau de
dans ma vie quoi donc
voilà merci merci d'avoir regardé une
vidéo d avoir partagé les avoir commenté
franchement vous êtes une communauté
incroyable j'enrage fois que si les
commentaires que je vois les échanges
enfin il ya un niveau et je suis fier
je suis heureux et fier de vous avoir et
je trouve ça cool et j'espère que vous
serez plus en plus nombreux et que
malgré ce nom que la qualité ne passera
pas donc merci bonjour merci
regardez le tee shirt que je viens
d'acheter je trouve ça trop cool faux